I'm Laura Ingram this is Ingram angle
from Washington tonight thanks for
spending time with us sabotaging America
that's the focus of tonight's angle
[Music]
now you know we spend more than what 800
billion dollars a year in our military
and the Pentagon just announced another
1.2 billion dollars in assistance for
Ukraine today
but for almost two and a half years our
elected officials have allowed our
country to be invaded yeah I'm going to
say it invaded overrun by millions of
people who are gaming the system by
fraudulently claiming Asylum now
countless others several hundred
thousand at least have gotten away
they've run they've walked they've
waited across the border we have no idea
who these people are where they are or
what they're doing
now of course this invasion is being
encouraged and even facilitated by the
Biden Administration Biden's puppeteers
they plan this because their goal is to
fundamentally change America not just
politically every four years at The
Ballot Box every two years but
culturally
now remember in their thinking that old
traditional America is rotten to its
core
racism is real in America
it has always been racism
the ugly poison in his long haunted and
plagued our nation
in their view the old America is too
prone to patriotic outbursts and
displays
I was on Long Island this weekend uh
visiting a really dear friend and I was
really Disturbed I saw you know dozens
and dozens of pickup trucks with uh you
know uh explicatives against Joe Biden
on the back of them uh Trump flags and
some cases just dozens of American flags
which you know is also just disturbing
because essentially the message was
clear it was this is my country this is
not your country
illness
now those views of hers were spawned
let's face it by Barack Obama like when
he apologized for America overseas or
made comments like this
I believe in American exceptionalism
just as I suspect that the Brits believe
in British exceptionalism and the Greeks
believe in Greek exceptionalism what a
bozo I mean in other words America is
the place no better than anywhere else
so stop acting like it is people
and we all know the leftists calling the
shots today are even more radical than
Obama was they actually detest Americans
who still believe in our Constitution
and our declaration after all those
documents were written by a bunch of
dead white guys it's certainly not
sacred all right let's start there the
Constitution is kind of trash it was
written by slavers and colonists and
white people who were willing to make
deals with slavers and colonists
now Democrats are far more afraid of the
Americans that elected Trump in 2016 of
the 74 million who voted for him in 2020
than they are of the cartels who are
right now shipping fentanyl across the
border to kill our kids
the racially motivated violent
extremists as a group are the most
dangerous uh of the domestic violence
extremist groups and within that the
white supremacists are the most
dangerous and most least lethal Now
American citizens who disagree with this
dark vision of the country the ones who
exercise and defend their first and
second amendment rights they're the real
danger to democracy Biden's border
zealots they don't lose any sleep over
the gang bangers the terrorists the
child rapists the domestic abusers the
drug pushers mixed in with all the poor
huddled masses at the border I had a
worried about them
and just as bad if you dare question
their border sabotage you'll be tarred
as a racist and a xenophobe it's the
oldest trick in the book
and it's all a lie we know they're lying
I think they know their line
because you have every right to demand
answers
but since the media have been Biden's
partners in crime the White House feels
totally justified in simply blowing them
off
we hear from the president on title well
I would say you heard from the president
just this past Friday he did a he did a
interview a sit-down interview
works and talked about title 42 talked
about immigration so the American people
did hear directly from the president on
this issue I don't have anything else to
share in the next couple of days about
the present schedule so I'll just leave
it there
Cavalier right well last Friday well I
don't think anyone told her and their
area diet group of staffers over there
at the com shop that a few hours earlier
The Washington Post of all places
published an editorial hitting Biden's
refusal to face the media writing
President Biden hasn't dropped the
microphone he appears to have lost it Mr
Biden's turning into a news media evader
and it's harmful to his presidency and
the nation wow
now perhaps it was those belated
complaints from his usual supporters
perhaps it was the reports of the Border
catastrophe itself but Joe Biden
unbelievable did a very short presser
with after his meeting with speaker
McCarthy and he touched on the ending of
title 42. title 42 is the United States
ready for the surge of people
I spent uh
I might get close to an hour with uh
with the Mexican president today uh
we're doing all we can are in the
process of setting up Res
offices in Colombia and other places
where you can or someone seeking a solid
can go first so but it remains to be
seen it's going to be chaotic for a
while
that's it
it's going to be chaotic for a while
my seventh grader could do better than
that now that answer alone shows that
the man is unfit for the presidency
but I'm telling you tonight don't hold
your breath for any tough media
follow-ups
millions of illegals are going to filter
across the United States and there'll be
little to no accountability for what
happens with them next instead just
expect cries for amnesty
it's a vicious cycle of lawlessness that
we're seeing
our citizens and those immigrants who
came the right way will be the ones
paying the bills that are piling up from
Biden's border experiment
keeping these illegals housed fed
educated and their health care covered
is going to cost hundreds of billions of
dollars over time
and you have every right to demand
answers as to why this is happening what
is the greatest country on Earth refuse
to enforce its borders certainly
interested in forcing other countries
borders
and don't by the way fall for this
nonsense that Biden's DHS is suddenly
planning some tough enforcement stuff to
deal with all the bad guys who are
trying to sneak in now it's all theater
zero action it's actually
counterproductive and it was called out
by such from the border patrol Union
saying nothing like publicly announcing
that dangerous people will be arrested
while warning them ahead of time exactly
where to run and try to avoid arrest
this entire operation is a sad joke
another pandering PR stunt serious law
enforcement leaders don't behave this
way
yeah
no es bueno
with things spiraling out of control the
White House came up though with another
strategy for calming everyone's nerves
so the president is is closely has been
closely Consulting with the vice
president on this they have have had
several conversations on this issue and
so again when it comes to issues that
matter to the American people they're
very much partners
kamala's a partner on the border partner
in what
devastation demoralization
as unpopular as Biden is these days and
he's at a record low 36 percent she's
even more disliked and distrusted
but hey there's an idea
instead of boots on the ground why not
just get creative with what they're
playing over the loudspeakers at our
ports of Entry
I think it's very important for us at
every moment in time and certainly this
one to see the moment
in time in which we existed the
significance of the passage of time
right so when you think about it there
is great significance to the passage of
time it is time for us to do what we
have been doing in that time is every
day
well that should send them running in
the other direction and that's the angle
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else